in this video we'll be talking about the
differences between chemical and
electrical
synapses so electrical synapses also
known as Gap Junction couple synapses
involve direct physical contact or
connection between the cytoplasms of the
pre syapse and the post synapse here you
can see the pre syapse in green and post
synapse in yellow and all these red
channels are known as connection
connectons which connect the pre and
post synapse it actually forms a tunnel
through which neurotransmitter can flow
from the pre to the post synapse it's
not only neurotransmitters but also
metabolites ATP Etc can be transported
through these channels now let us zoom
into these channels to understand the
architecture in bit more details in
contrast chemical synapse has post
synaptic receptors shown here when the
pre synaptic action po potential reach
the nerve terminal it leads to
neurotransmitter release
neurotransmitter binds to the post
synaptic receptor for example in a
cholinergic system atile choline would
bind to Coline the acti choline receptor
in the post synapse and this would lead
to opening of the liated Ion channel and
allow cation to influx and this is the
post synaptic event which would lead to
another uh potential potential change in
the post synapse
now let's talk about the electrical
synapse in bit more details in
electrical
synapse these channels are known as
connexons connexons are composed of
protein subunit known as
conines now each conexon is typically
made up of six Conex in protein subunits
and they are arranged in a cylindrical
hexameric form so we cut through a
cross-section through this uh connection
channel to show you this particular U
particular architecture now these
channels
allow the flow of ions
neurotransmitters ATP and also big
molecules through it so not only it
allow the transport of neurotransmitters
but also it allows transport of
metabolites that is super important that
means the prapt and post synapse uh
cytoplasm is kind of
interrelated and connected
internally electrical synapses are
really beneficial why they the
transmission velocity is very fast and
the transmission of signal can also be
biral that means the pr syapse and post
syapse are connected so the signal can
move from PR syapse to post synapse also
it can move in the opposite direction
which is not possible in the chemical
synapse so in chemical synapse that flow
is unidirectional now electrical synapse
are found in mostly invertebrate such as
crayfish and this is vital for
coordinating the rhythmic movement as
seen in their escape reflex now just
like cray crayfish these kind of Gap
Junction couple synapses are common in
insects arnes molas and Crustaceans but
not only in these invertebrates it can
also be found in
vertebrate for example in early uh
synaptogenesis these channels are also
found in humans
now let me talk about why does chemical
synapse even exist because chemical
synapse has a slow transmission velocity
so why should one bother with chemical
synapse now the chemical synapses are
highly highly
modulatory now electrical synapses are
found in human brain in early stage of
neuronal development they show
synchronous activity because they are
interconnected with each other as the
synaps is mature and the circuits mature
the synapses become more chemical in
nature due to neurom modulation the
synapses become asynchronous I mean the
overall neuronal circuit activity
becomes asynchronous here you can see in
the left side the neuron neurons are
blinking or firing an in an asynchronous
manner whereas in the right side you can
see the Gap Junction coupled synapses
are firing coordinately so these kind of
changes happen during the human brain
development as well
now let us quickly compare between these
two synapses when it comes to speed of
transmission chemical synapses are slow
electrical synapses are very fast spec
when it comes to specificity chemical
synapses are highly specific and
electrical synapsis doesn't show the
property of specificity when it comes to
plasticity chemical synapses are highly
plastic whereas electrical synapses are
not plastic let us try to understand
plasticity in bit more details
plasticity is a parameter that allows
the synapse to change
with respect to the stimulus so this is
a important property using this property
a chemical synapse can grow stronger
synaptic strengthening can happen also
using this same principle synaptic
weakening or synaptic pruning can also
happen so new synapses could be made and
old synapsis could be broken using this
plasticity principle now let's talk
about this particular uh differences in
a quick overview so first we looked at
speed of transmission then we looked at
specificity lastly we looked at
plasticity these are the key principles
that differentiate between chemical and
electrical
synapses so I hope this video was
informative get notes and flash cards in
our Facebook page and Instagram Channel
links are provided in the description
you can support our Channel using super
tanks see you in next
[Music]
video